je vous posais des questions concernant
la musique disco parce que vous avez vu
que l'album de ben laden notamment ce
titre qui nous a faits en début
d'émission qui
folie je vous posais des questions sur
le disco on va prendre des choses et
chéri vous avez à chaque fois quatre
possibilités de réponse est un gage si
vous vous trompez vous allez devoir
faire le gage
si vous donner la bonne réponse vous
choisirez quelqu'un automatique qui fera
le gage à votre part ou la place
d'accords echiré attention on va jouer
d'abord avec blake n sportif black m
vous jouez pour un souci qui mèneront
ces poissons c'est à dire un smoothie
criminal c'est un smoothie au piment
d'accord là laquelle de ces anecdotes
sur boney m
bonnet mc ça bien sûr merci boney m
c'est ça
[Musique]
laquelle de ces anecdotes sur boney m
est vrai le groupe n'a sorti qu'un seul
album
l'effet du groupe font vraiment du
bonnet m 1 tous les membres sont
français ou ce n'est pas le leader du
groupe qui chante à laquelle m à ton
avis black'n black aimes-tu pas envie de
me tromper
le premier le premier ok maintenant j'ai
pas dit oui mais t'as pas envie de te
tromper le premier peut venir te tromper
j'ai bien compris la csg ce que tu dis
la dictada alors tu prends quoi c'est
mon dernier mot je sais mon dernier mot
le dit nous dit eh bien c'est une bonne
réponse
vous
merci il connaît kinoise ce n'est pas le
leader du groupe qui chante bobby
farrell de son vrai nom alfonso farrell
fait du playback sur les chances et de
leur producteur frank farian
donc en fait c'est pas lui qui chantait
et luz est exquise et non il
il enlevait des poils de son torse comme
ça il est jeté les gens qui fait ouais
le chanteur de boney mieux y paraît que
ces sessions délire à la fin de l'année
mais ça repousse lévitation reste une
fois que c'est vrai mais black m je
rigole pas voilà et donc black m
tu vas nous aurons quelqu'un qui va
boire le smoothie que maintenant c'est
un smoothie au piment
tu choisis qui la fonde et n'hésite pas
alors c'est lequel le smoothie grimmer
ça doit être ça ouais c'est ça va
exactement mais bon un peu alors je peux
jouer n'importe qui et badoit sur
n'importe qui je sors public un nom mal
et je prends par exemple est bon mais
non non non non elle est mon cas
[Musique]
jama bravo en tout cas bravo jamal a
fait allez on enchaîne avec vous
d'ailleurs benjamin vous pouvez jouer
benjamin et vous jouez pour à michael
jackson n'a jamais joué par michael
jackson il ya six passes ne quittez pas
aujourd'hui ne quittez pas à michael
jackson ça consiste à se mettre du
chocolat sur les dans ce cas classique
ici et à imiter jacquouille la
fripouille et chanter du michael jackson
d'accord on va parler du groupe abba
[Applaudissements]
l'acronyme du groupe abba est composé
des initiales des prénoms des membres
qui sont agnetha björn benny anni frid
ou bien agnès verte
bruno anna aïcha bilal match ira biram
agathe à bergame brossé et alphonse à
comment il s'appelle
je rappelle si vous répondez bien c'est
bon pour vous choisissez quelqu'un qui
fera m'arrangerait qui fera le michael
jackson
sinon c'est le fait il allait non merci
parce que c'est la réponse bien que ça
me dit quelque chose de la réponse à je
pense la réponse à mme agnetha björn
benny anni frid c'est une bonne
il faut faire un mec jacquouille c'est à
dire vous vous retournez vous mettez du
chocolat sur les solides et vous devez
faire
michael jackson vous soigner et qui sait
pas faire ce que j'ai réagi comme al
akhawayn tu veux ou tu veux n'en prend
plus en alors oui vous savez j'ai bien
envie de prendre ma mis le pays en garde
à vue le temps des boues
retournez-vous est une fête bien sûr
faction jacques 34 oui vous nous faites
michael jackson et à sang
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour la différence avec l'avant
l'isabelle magnifique jamais s'en est
pris c'est pas dans alors ça ça
franchement c'est pas drôle du tout
d'abord oui mais c'est pas drôle ça va
vous sinon décrocher votre mère j'ai
mangé bien qu'est ce qu'il ya voilà je
vais m'en occuper
dans la vie vous verrez des images la
cuisine c'est à vous vous jouez pourra
retourner de dalida
vous allez vous mettre dodo loucher avec
une perruque vous retourner chanter
laissez moi danser
[Applaudissements]
m
elle est allée sur une autre émission
web assez bon fan en question vous jouez
avec nous chez vous qui est cette
personne qui est cette personne
attention cette personne et qui le
jumeau de bernard montiel la vraie voix
de plastic bertrand mais le militaire
des village people
aujourd'hui où le chanteur de taiwan
devenu plombier ce qui a baissé
là c'est la cua la réponse est donc
militaires des village people
aujourd'hui
alors oui non non vous dites quoi vous
aider et c'est une bonne réponse de
questions
[Applaudissements]
alex voilées qu'on embrasse quelqu'un
qui incarnait dans l'est ou dans les
village people le militaire est
l'officier de navy pendant de nombreuses
années
choisissez qui khalid a souffert dalida
maxime maximini allez-y attention
attention on n'a peu on a paru utile
sont ils sont très recherchés on est ans
arbore des lieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maxime godefroy maxime tu es d'ailleurs
dispensés voilà ce que des passionnés
mais tellement bon là dessus tu est
dispensé voilà contrairement au dos jean
michel maire vous jouez pour faire une
bouille à facettes
c'est à dire s'humidifier le visage et
mettre sa tête dans un saladier rempli
de paille est une petite tête tandis que
l'arrêt vous ferez comme ça oui oh là là
mais qu'il est con mais celle qui a
écrit les paroles de la chanson
interprétée par patrick juvet ou sur les
femmes
[Musique]
à votre avis qui interprété ça qui a
chanté ça d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qui a
écrit ça écrit ainsi puisque chanter on
sait que c'est patrick jury qui a écrit
ça jean michel jarre marc cerrone andré
manoukian ou faudel cerrone cerrone la
baie vous êtes sur ce point
et bien c'est jean michel jarre je vous
dis c'est jean michel jarre donc voila
merci donc jean-michel vous nous faites
tout de suite une bouillotte passagers
vont pas l'intention c'est parti jean
louis livi va direct
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean michel jarre